this video is sponsored by surf shark
okay yeah this act was the best
it's absolutely incredible and not just
that this is easily the most tragic arc
thus far that tackles some of the most
intense subject matters
while focusing on an aspect of the story
that has been at the forefront of it
since the very beginning its characters
and what effect they have on luffy
building up to the most tragic crescendo
the likes of which
affected me on such a profound level i
had to take a step away from my desk and
stare out a window for a few minutes
this arc made me laugh it made me lean
in
and it made me ugly cry more than any
other part of one piece has that i've
read through
and so without further ado i'm totally
not mark and these are my first
impressions of
thoughts on and review for a crazy
little story that was so much fun and
felt so much bigger than i thought it
would
this is the beautiful brutal and bubbly
japanese archipelago
but before i dive into the subject
matter for this week's review however i
need to address a couple of things from
my last video that i was perhaps unclear
on or got flat out wrong so let's
explore them a lot of people were
claiming that maurya didn't relinquish
the shadows to luffy that he eventually
lost the battle of wills between luffy
beating him up and lola's crew screaming
and demanding for their shadows to
return
this coupled with the fact that he was
crushed by a building created the
perfect storm of circumstance for his
defeat and their shadow's ultimate
reuniting but
what led me to my conclusions in the
last video were the following
this panel taken from chapter 456
wherein maurya specifically says and i
quote
that's right no matter how defiant a
person is their shadows
are obedient to me this told me that
willpower had nothing to do with it but
perhaps i read into that wrong moreover
this also led me to believe that by
default the shadows were servants of him
he even demonstrates this by commanding
luffy's shadow in that very chapter
which would explain to me why the
shadows were only with luffy for a
limited time and why they would be with
moria indefinitely as it is part of his
devil fruit power
also there's a specific manga panel in
chapter 463
wherein moria explains and once again i
quote even if you beat me
or kill me the zombies simply lose their
master their shadows stay where they
are my powers control the shadows to get
what you want you'll have to make me
tell the shadows to go back to their
original owners
since i'm their current master this
therefore implies to me
that even if moria lost consciousness or
his will
the shadows wouldn't return to their
owners anyway and to me that sort of was
the entire point of this particular
dialogue exchange in the manga and when
i saw that it was contradicted at the
very end
it sort of conflicted in my mind so
therefore
when i saw that maurya was losing
consciousness and was about to be
defeated
i was then surprised when the shadows
went back to their owners
so i hope at the very least these two
quotes being at the back of my head will
inform you why i came to the conclusions
that i did regarding the last video
another comment that i saw claimed that
i expect everything to be foreshadowed
and
to that i say i don't appreciate it when
plot pivotal moments are dictated by
coincidence
that's a preference i have and always
have had i have no issue with anyone
liking what they like but
for me if things happen for no reason
that dictate the conclusions to stories
then what's the point of being told the
information beforehand leading up to
that ending if it doesn't inform the
events of that climax
in other words i don't expect stuff like
moria's devil fruit abilities to be
foreshadowed when he's revealing or
explaining to us what they are and how
they work
in the beginning that's exposition and
it's vital for a story what i do mind
however is when there are techniques
revealed at the last
hour without explanation that change the
course of events
for instance imagine if when luffy
returned the second time to face
crocodile armed with all that yuba water
imagine if you will luffy returned from
the desert but we had no idea how he got
the water he just
has it that would feel weird and
contrived and
wouldn't make sense in the slightest in
another way what if i said luffy
suddenly managed to become
invincible and just beat him in one
punch that isn't foreshadowed that isn't
earned and therefore it wouldn't make
sense or be satisfying for a conclusion
and in a less extreme way than that
that's sort of how i saw the events
unfold with the end of the moria fight
as he introduced abilities that sort of
came out of nowhere
and once again i need to reiterate this
these are just my opinions and if you
loved what happened in the moriar arc
then i'm sincerely really happy that you
exist
and love it i don't want people to
dislike anything i'm just letting you
know how i felt about it and really i'm
not holding one piece here to some sort
of special standard i'm consistent with
this across
everything i watch it just so happens
that one piece is great and not breaking
these rules that i enjoy
something of note however that others
mentioned time and again in the comments
was that moria was unconscious
and just like kroc and alabasta that
should be enough for him to relinquish
control
of the shadows and his subsequent devil
fruit abilities which
honestly would have been totally fine i
just got caught up in the aforementioned
quotes
thinking that specifically stated that
couldn't happen
but perhaps i misinterpreted that
regardless i'm getting a little lost in
the weeds here and i just wanted to make
it clear as to why i held the opinions i
did about moria after aj
sent me more and more comments from you
guys they demonstrated a lot of things i
didn't pay attention to
like the thematic relevance and elements
that maurya offers the story in its
horror aesthetic
with that said however this review is
about zamboni archipelago and maurya
will no doubt be back later as he did
survive in the last arc so if i have
more to talk about regarding him in the
future i'll be sure to mention it when
he comes up
now onward to our archipelago bubble
place
all right this arc was so good i
searched the dictionary for the most
positive word in it i could find to
describe how good i thought it was
the word i found was ineffable which
means too great or extreme to be
expressed or described in words
which it was this arc was bloody
ineffable in every sense of the word
i am first and foremost a massive fan of
tragedy in storytelling and boy
oh boy this one got me it got me good
tugging at my heartstrings more than any
story i
ever read watched or listened to heck
this made me cry more than some of the
funerals i've been to in my life
and so in order to tackle this properly
i want to discuss sections of it
hopefully that way i'll tackle
everything you all want me to so
yeah let's begin
duvall gave me a great laugh and proved
to be a fantastic way of introducing us
to the world this arc explores and takes
place
within as the gang arrive back at the
red line looking to cross it for the
second time
only this time on the other side of the
world
of that sense of progression it becomes
abundantly clear that they need to cross
specifically
underwater and that is when we meet this
girl
kami a mermaid they saved from a sea
monster
and she is specifically very important
to the story in more ways than one but
none perhaps more important than the
fact that she links us back with
hachi the fishman from arlung park if
you remember that ona took
a lot of care and effort in exploring
during the cover chapters
portion of his storytelling which all
these cover chapters seem to carry
so much importance and adds so much to
the overall narrative
it's nuts essentially kami requests of
the guys involved to save her friend
hachi from this sinister looking
helmet-wearing monstrous entity known as
duvall
and once the straw hats eventually
arrived to free hachi from them the
atmosphere surrounding his unmasking was
built
up by oda so perfectly to something
menacing to be perfectly honest during
this section i was full on expecting it
to be someone like don krieg because of
the armor but then
was i wrong and boy was the reveal so
much better than i thought
[Music]
i'm so so glad that this wasn't paid off
in any sort of serious way
and i love it all the more for it it
plays on an established joke regarding
sanji's wanted poster with that
specifically acting as the inspiration
for the altercation in the first place
climaxing with luffy sanji and the rest
of the crew totally winning the scrap
rearranging duvall's face into
surprisingly a far
more handsome one all the while earning
hachi's freedom
all in all this small self-contained
little mini arc was a really nice story
that served to introduce us to kami the
mermaid to reintroduce us to hachi
to establish his motivations to help
redeem himself in the eyes of nami
and to provide us with a means of
crossing the red line and so in order to
help hachi regain some semblance of
conscience he will bring them to a man
in sabon the archipelago wherein he will
coat their ship in a substance that
allows them to sail underwater through
fishman island and
under the red line into the new world
and while this seems straightforward and
safe
nothing could be further from the truth
world building sabande archipelago the
world building in this arc works pretty
much the exact same way as all the other
arcs in one piece
absolutely brilliantly a lot of people
will disregard arcs like thriller bark
and label them as something
as simple as bad or poorly written
because it's sandwiched between arcs
like eddie's lobby and
this and while those arcs are phenomenal
in their own right
i want to make it known that they work
as well as they do because they were
built
up to by these smaller lesser arcs you
can't have an alabasta arc without
reverse mountain little garden and
whiskey peak coming before it
you can't really have any climatic worth
anything without prior buildup
in other words you need cab moments in
order to appreciate the action and you
need lower stakes
in order to appreciate stuff like what's
about to go down later
don't worry i will get to that within
the archipelago the crew explorer
odadrop feeds us little pieces of
information regarding its world via maps
modes of transportation how its economy
works
and of course its culture but this
archipelago more so than any other place
in the one piece world we've seen so far
has some of the darkest themes explored
like the selling of humans
public executions and slavery among
other such activities
it's pretty surreal and while i was
reading it i was really taken aback and
pleased with the subject matter chosen
to be explored here in order to bring
this world to life
more so because of a certain promise
luffy made to hachi not to interfere or
cause destruction within
a certain group and it just so happens
that certain group is
these nobles referred to as celestial
dragons by the regular people and
themselves are some of the most
insufferable deplorable and
sickeningly irredeemable characters i've
ever come across
yet in fiction let alone one piece it's
sort of like oda said to himself
okay let's think of the worst possible
human traits and combine them into one
character
only he didn't do that and he made a
bunch of characters that are all equally
awful and they work so amazingly well to
the catalyst of the horrific events that
eventually unfold in the story
thereafter
these people are revealed to be from a
noble lineage 800 years ago
20 kings banded together to create the
world government and these celestial
dragons are their descendants
unveiled in their opening scene
executing a former pirate for trying to
run away from them
trying to run away from slavery
essentially however this primarily
serves the purpose of informing us of
how a certain system of human
trafficking within the archipelago works
and how slaves are made where these
colors that if their owner so chooses
i want to thank surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring today's video
in the ocean of online content there's a
lot of websites that take your info
without you even knowing it but you can
swim under their radar using
surfsharkvpn with this particular
service you can stop websites from
tracking your info and selling targeted
ads to you online
completely protecting your privacy
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a friend about
something and it pops up in your ads
plus with surfshark hardlock id
protection you'll even get an alert when
some rando jerk is trying to break into
your email but one of my personal
favorite features of surfshark is that
you can see content that's not available
in your area for instance did you know
that right now on netflix you can have
the first 130 episodes of one piece well
if you live in a country where that's
not available you can just log in with
surfshark and you can get access to that
or
any other show or film that that isn't
normally available for you
so if you want both freedom and
protection online click the link in the
description and use code tnm it not only
gives you a whopping 85 percent off the
regular price
but also three months of service totally
for free
surf shark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee so there's no risk
to even try it out for yourself
so if this service sounds interesting to
you or you want to support the channel
please
check it out now back to the video my
goal in life
has more power than all of your blades
well my blades are very heavy they'll
knock you for a loop
then you can dream all you want
never try to be deep with a fish
[Music]
at a later time with this arc there's
this just great scene with zorro so
this celestial dragon guy arrives to the
area riding a slave demanding medical
personnel to stop helping the wounded
and to instead bow before him as he
passes he then
in a classy fashion demands one of the
nurses to be his
13th wife before subsequently banishing
wives one through five because he's
quote
tired of them and shoots her fiance
in front of her and this is when i saw
zoro
walk up to him once again oda using
dramatic irony wherein we the readers
know more than zoro does in this
particular situation
which honestly i adore because it
creates anticipation and tension within
a scene
we know that this celestial dragon guy
has no idea how impossibly powerful zoro
is
and we also know that zoro has no idea
how important it is
not to cause waves around these
particular tyrants
so needless to say immediately and
without warning the tension in the scene
shoots up from a 5 to a 10
as the celestial dragon shoots at zorro
and with ease
zorro dodges but out of nowhere one of
the big bounties in the area pulls him
to the side
and plays off the encounter as if zorro
is dead to get them off his trail
she sort of reprimands him for his
behavior and reminds them that this
isn't the right thing to do but
zoro sort of ignores this and takes the
injured fiance to get medical attention
in this scene it's great to see that
zorro is a really good person despite
not necessarily touting himself as one
it's a great character moment and what's
more is that once again
it gets over that these celestial dragon
characters are the scum of the earth and
don't deserve the air we all breathe and
certainly not the elitist bubbled air
they breathe they are certainly not
powerful
and actually speaking of powerful that
reminds me as it happens the archipelago
the straw hats are currently searching
around looking for this guy that can
coat their ship with this awesome
substance
also is a popular spot for those that
made their journey across the ground
line their own way
before they move on to the new world and
as it happens all of the other young
pirates that made a name for themselves
across the ground line through various
different sailing routes
are all on the archipelago 2 at the same
time
including luffy and zoro there are 11
people in total having bounties higher
than 100 million berries
on the archipelago right now and with
one in particular
having a higher bounty than even luffy
which makes things
all sorts of interesting and within an
entire chapter ona takes the time to
introduce each of these fine upstanding
criminals to
us along with their bounty numbers so i
guess these will be mainstays in the
series moving forward question mark
the introduction of these new pirate
characters the presentation and scenes
depicting the celestial dragons
and the boisterous enthusiasm luffy
tackles every subsequent situation with
serve to paint for me an intensely set
of interesting parameters for the story
already to operate within but that is
ignoring the single most
important aspect of what made the story
so tense and phenomenal for me
they are right next to the world naval
hq
so if anything arises that needs to be
addressed they will most
definitely come raining down on luffy
and his friends
so with all of these pieces in play the
story takes a turn into something
interesting
and awful starting with calming the
mermaids
kidnapping i haven't touched on this
much yet but a key aspect that added a
ton of tension in this act for me
was the underlying secrecy hachi and
kami were forced to operate under
apparently their kind isn't welcome in
the archipelago and moreover
mermaids being notoriously difficult to
catch as well as being incredibly rare
are one of the most sought after
specimens during these human
trafficking auctions which on its own is
incredibly disgusting and cruel
needless to say however the crew all
split up even going as far as to use the
help of their new allies in the flying
fish riders and that's when they
eventually all discover that kami is
being sold at an auction in the
archipelago labeled number one
and there we get to see the fiscal
struggle for comey's freedom
or enslavement happen right before our
eyes
and in traditional one-piece fashion the
most interesting part of it is revealed
to be something we didn't even see
coming through a character we learn is
called
rayleigh more on him later nami now
armed with 200 million berries
all the money they have in the world
from their adventures
she is ready to give it all up in order
to save
kami but before she even has a chance to
place a bid
guess who comes through with an absurdly
high bidding to outbid
literally everyone
yeah i know and what's more is that
during this scene we also get to see
law and kid two guys we were introduced
to as part of the 11 bounties higher
than 100 million present on the
archipelago
with kidd being the one that has the
highest bounty both of these characters
presents offer something interesting to
the occasion in terms of personality but
they also sport
some of the best sleek character designs
i've seen come out of this series in a
long long time
i'm guessing they play a big role later
judging by their character designs
and i guess by later i mean right now as
when luffy sees what this celestial
dragon does at the auction
without delay and in perfect luffy
fashion
delivers one of the most satisfying
punches i've
ever in
i don't think i've ever wanted a
character to be punched more than i
wanted luffy to punch
this bratty celestial dragon
character
and it's in this moment i realized how
unbelievably thankful i was
for how the navy is represented in this
story because
it's utterly brilliant for pacing we all
knew that when luffy was told not to
react to these celestial folks that he
eventually would inevitably
interact and start causing a big deal
specifically because we have it at the
back of our heads then we gotta remain
composed and out of trouble to avoid the
navy
and funnily enough thinking back to my
thoughts at the beginning of this series
i was so so scared that the navy was
going to be a team
rocket type organization because towards
the start of the story they didn't
really show their hand
and what they were capable of and the
very fact that the navy is a massively
imposing
force in these oceans of one piece helps
the story on
so so many levels in creating great
wonderful tension
this is where oda starts to drive this
story a little more dangerously flirting
with tension even more
and driving the story in a way that
makes me go hey
oda you okay buddy so this pulls off
with these three heartthrobs of one
piece is cool and all and we get a
really cool action sequence where all of
them work together i also get the
distinct feeling that as the series goes
on the significance of this moment will
feel all the better as i reread or watch
it when i'm finished
but perhaps the best sign that luffy is
growing as a captain comes from this
scene too
where he opts to think of his friends
first and run away to regroup for safety
after all this isn't something that
needs to be dealt with they have kami
they have
everyone all they have to do now is lay
low and avoid everything which is a nice
piece of character growth and subtle
foreshadowing
for what's to come but anyway they
eventually find this guy
who will coat their ship and man this
guy
is a wild ride
[Music]
really this guy is goldie rogers
first mate holy jesus on a bicycle i
was not prepared for him to say that
like at all
and what's more is that one of the 10
000 theories i actually made way back
when
turned out to be true many videos ago i
made a prediction that there was no way
roger was captured without giving
himself up or something to that effect
he was just too powerful and wouldn't
you know it
i nailed it apparently he got really
really sick disbanded his group
and ultimately surrendered which on its
own i'm sort of curious about but i'm
going to wait and see how this
arc itself plays out before i start
speculating when i read this i literally
stood up for my chair and held my hands
high
triumphantly remember kids if you want
to predict something correctly
all you got to do is throw thousands of
speculations at the wall and eventually
one will be gold amidst the sea of
inconclusive and
time travel speculation which i'm
deeply embarrassed about during this
section there's an incredibly
interesting conversation that takes
place
shanks is even brought up in
conversation and luffy is told that he
once worked for goldie roger
as apprentice which honestly was really
fun to read through as we don't really
get many chances for luffy to actually
talk or mention shanks
what's more is that i often make note of
these character breakdowns at the
beginning of every volume
but one character that has literally
always been there regardless of whether
or not he shows up in that volume
is shanks he's always there and i think
that's fitting as
he is still sort of a driving
influential force in luffy's life
which on its own is a wonderful touch i
think and
finally in this scene there are two
character interactions i
really really enjoyed firstly as
rayleigh explains how
roger read the pornoglyphs robin begins
getting sucked more and more into this
conversation but when she learns how
important it is for her to discover this
on her own she immediately stops probing
for information which is a nice little
character moment for her
but that's not even the half of it
[Applause]
when usopp asks this guy really to tell
him about where the one piece might be
or where he thinks it is
luffy demanded not to know what he knows
about the location
of the one-piece treasure which on its
own is a
really metal thing to say but also
perfectly in line and full of character
for someone like luffy to say
if anyone were to stumble into you
watching this episode or to pick up the
manga at this particular chapter
without any context they would still get
a fantastic idea of who
luffy really is based on this one
decision but
moreover during this arc a few things
caught my attention as worth keeping in
mind to think about
it's let known to us that ace is up for
execution which
i mean if that happened would mean all
at war with whitebeard and his forces
i guess this is perhaps what shanks was
trying to prevent when he met with
whitebeard earlier
and i think if anything this
circumstance that ace now finds himself
in reinforces the notion that no one is
truly safe in this world when we first
saw ace he was this cam
collected fun-loving incredibly
impressive and supremely powerful person
one that quite literally outshines luffy
in every way by his own admission
even as a child when he himself didn't
have devil fruit powers
and so now that he finds himself in the
circumstance he's in
while i read this i thought man i wonder
what luffy has in store for him if
something like that
can happen to ace and boy was i not
ready for what was to come next
and this is where oda turns off cruise
control and starts veering into oncoming
traffic before continuing to drive
erratically while i lose my ever loving
mind
once this intensely interesting scene
where raleigh describes some info about
roger's past the gang decides to lay low
for three days while he works on coding
their ship
when
out of nowhere standing before all none
of the straw hats together
stands the single most formidable foe
the gang has ever encountered
kuma and this is where things go from
carefree to
ludicrously intense in the blink of an
eye showing no signs of slowing down
or mercy kuma begins unloading massive
attack after massive attack on each of
the straw hats without
reservation requiring every single one
of them to employ their own brand of
heroism
strategy and tenacity to create the
perfect storm of offense
to take out this once thought to be
invincible foe and trust me
this is not an easy effort this takes
every
last bit of energy these guys can muster
utilizing all of their best techniques
all of their power in one short burst of
combined
coordinated assault this scene more than
any other demonstrates the crew at their
absolute
best all on the same page all in the
same circumstance
helping each other and overcoming in
their own way
a massive threat i do not want to
undersell
how immense this particular occasion
feels however
once this giant enemy does hit the floor
it becomes immediately apparent
that everyone is spent they have no
energy left
and that's when
[Music]
things have now gone from a bad
situation to a
dire one as we now know that the only
option the crew have is
to run away which as it turns out
isn't a good one all this time luffy has
been
screaming the order for them to try and
escape and as his friends get taken away
from him
one after the other he starts taking
more and more desperate attempts to save
them but
as the last one vanishes right from
before his eyes
he falls to his knees weeping this tiny
section of this small scene got me more
than
any other chapter or scene in the entire
series so far
watching this character who is described
quite literally in the front of every
volume as
someone with boundless optimism to see
this poor character
crushed by a loss and circumstance
before being erased too
broke me in a way i wasn't even remotely
prepared for
this arc forces you to cope and accept
the situation's worsening atmosphere
in a natural but uncomfortably fast way
that places you or at least tries to
place you in the same frantic
desperate feeling the character feels
and this is achieved not just in the
escalating action and violence
but in the literal plot being erased
from right before our eyes
every single character in this straw hat
crew has had their own individual story
in this series
zorro and luffy in romance dawn nami in
orange town
usopp in syrup village sanji in bharate
chopper in drum island robin in alabasta
frankie in water 7 and brooke in
thriller bark
remove these characters and it quite
literally sucks the character and
purpose out of this world we've known
these characters for the exact same
amount of time as luffy
we have the same connection to them as
he does which puts us in a unique
position wherein we as readers can judge
luffy's orders and read into them what
they might mean to him
and us i care about all of them and the
truly terrifying aspect and part of this
entire scene was
i don't think i would have made a single
different decision than what luffy did
which just reinforces this sense of
desperation we feel as readers so
palpably when robin finally vanishes
before luffy's eyes
and so like luffy my heart sank
and i felt a severe pit in the middle of
my stomach like i had just received
real life bad news no other story
ever in my life invoked such a real
raw guttural response from me and i
ugly cried on this page like i stayed on
this page for probably
10 minutes before turning it to finish
the chapter and even as i write this my
heart is still
racing with my hands slightly shaking
this scene affected me in such a
profoundly
different way than i was ever expecting
it to so much so i had to start writing
my thoughts right away
this part here that you're hearing me
speak right now this is the part of the
script i've actually written down first
i have so many thoughts i don't even
know how to process them for obvious
reasons i know that this most definitely
can't be the end of luffy's journey with
the rest of them
and that this kuma ability surely just
teleports them elsewhere or something to
that effect
but that doesn't matter because for me
the implication is one and the same in
this scene
luffy's single greatest fear has been
realized
he wasn't able to save any of them from
the dangers of the grand line
all of them had to go away and he was
powerless to do anything about it
thematically narratively and even
emotionally
this hit perfectly encompassing
literally the central through line of
the
entire series the ragtag camaraderie
that comes with the friends we've met
along the way
and what's interesting about this scene
also is that it comes right after luffy
demanded not to know more than he needed
to know about goldie roger and his past
regarding the one piece treasure because
he wants it to stay
fun luffy doesn't want power he doesn't
want to rule over anyone he doesn't even
really want the treasure beyond saying
that he himself found it
the journey that he's on to that
ultimate dream of his
is the reward that's luffy's treasure
his friends
the journey the adventure the excitement
that's what he's there for
and right before his eyes right before
our eyes
without having any power to manipulate
or control the dire situation
one after another the loyal
loving brave souls that pledged their
lives to luffy throughout this series
and
all together just one arc prior they
were all
taken away from him as he was forced to
watch
it all unfold luffy was forced to watch
himself once again
become alone and lose all of his friends
what an absurdly effective scene and
what a beautifully constructed arc
and that's what this is this was a
gorgeous arc in how elegant and light it
was
while being able to deliver such an
intensely passionate gut punch
that hit its mark right in my stomach
what this arc does better than any of
the others in my opinion is naturally
escalate tension more efficiently in a
shorter span of time
than pretty much any of the other arcs
climaxing in one of the most anxious
nerve-wracking struggles i've seen from
this series
ever and trust me i'm using the word
struggle in this instance with great
purpose
and utility this wasn't a fight this was
a statement
and luffy i think received that message
loud and clear like to put this into
perspective right
this act was so intensely good and
affected me on such a
cellular level that i for the first time
ever had to tweet out my
thoughts on it before i released this
video heck before i even finished the
script i tweeted that out
my god holy hell this arc was
stupidly good introducing new characters
that reveal so much about the past
a confirmation on a hunch i had from
videos ago that gold roger had to have
handed himself in over to the navy
because he would have been too powerful
receiving breadcrumbs of information
about the world's government that forced
me to put my thinking cap on more than i
was comfortable with in this video but
easily at the forefront of my brain i
have the characters and friends that
i've become deeply attached to over the
last two and a half months and 500
chapters
they are after vanishing and i don't
know where to
but all i do know is that i will be
covering it next week and when i do
i hope you'll be there to join me as
always i've been totally not mark i'll
see you all next week
thank you so much for watching
you